la chaleur alors maintenant je vais vous
faire un petit proposer un petit calcul
vous savez que dans ce pays on a décidé
de se lancer dans l'éolien offshore
l'éolien offshore aujourd'hui ses 25
milliards d'euros d'argent public
pierre vos impôts les miens et ce2 des
gens qui nous écoutent qui vont partir
dans le financement de ce dispositif qui
a encore moins d'intérêt que l'éolien
terrestre car s'il ya un truc qu'il faut
arrêter tout de suite c'est bien ça
c'est pas ce qu'il va se passer mais
s'il ya un truc qu'il faut arrêter tout
de suite c'est le lien gère avec les 25
milliards d'euros en question vous avez
de quoi payer 6000 euros
6000 euros de prime de conversion du
fuel à la pompe à chaleur eau 4 millions
de ménages français qui sont chauffées
au fioul qui sont souvent des ruraux
souvent précaires et souvent des gilet
jaune soit dit en passant
6000 euros de prime de conversion
dit autrement là vous auriez une
subvention aux énergies renouvelables
avec laquelle moi je vote des quatre
mains qu'on augmente mon taux
d'imposition pour payer ça je veux bien
mais qu'on me prélève un centime d'impôt
pour aller payer l'éolien offshore
c'est un truc de shadocks aucun intérêt